[Música]
la fiscalía de Nueva York que está
negociando con los abogados del
expresidente Donald Trump para leerle
los cargos de los que fue acusado por un
gran Jurado del distrito y que están
relacionados con el presunto pago de
sobornos a la actriz Tom milenials a
cambio de su silencio y con dineros de
su campaña presidencial de 2016 tron
advirtió que no podrá tener un juicio
justo
el presidente de Ecuador Guillermo lasso
reiteró su inocencia en el presunto caso
de malversación de fondos públicos y por
el que será llevado a juicio político en
la asamblea nacional el mandatario
Indicó que respeta la decisión de la
corte constitucional de dar luz verde al
procedimiento pero no la comparte
Jair bolsonaro regresó a Brasil después
de estar tres meses en Estados Unidos
del aeropuerto de Brasilia salió a la
sede de su partido liberal y luego llegó
a su casa en el país se enfrenta cinco
grandes investigaciones judiciales
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz comenzamos en
Estados Unidos donde el gran Jurado de
una corte de Nueva York ha acusó
formalmente al expresidente Donald Trump
por cargos que lo relacionan con el pago
de sobornos a cambio del silencio de la
actriz de cine para adultos milenios Es
la primera vez que un expresidente
estadounidense se enfrenta a la justicia
la fiscalía de Manhattan confirmó que ya
está en contacto con los abogados que
representan al ex mandatario para leerle
todos los cargos previamente hablamos
con Rafael Cox salomar él es
constitucionalista y profesor de derecho
de la Universidad del distrito Columbia
en Washington DC quien nos contó que
representa este caso para el país
bueno representa un momento
importante
que va a poner a prueba la independencia
judicial y comienza un proceso intenso
una lucha entre la defensa del
presidente Trump y los fiscales en Nueva
York todavía no tenemos acceso a la
acusación ese documento está sellado ese
pliego acusatorio mantiene sellado vamos
a tener conocimiento de de los cargos
específicos la semana que viene Rafael
Cox también nos contó qué es lo que
sigue ahora en el proceso judicial
contra el mandatario el proceso es que
él se presenta ante la fiscalía él Allí
se le va a tomar
las huellas dactilares se le va a
ingresar su información en el sistema se
presenta ante un magistrado ante un juez
que le lee esas acusaciones y él allí
hace su alegación de culpabilidad o no
culpabilidad
él no se le va a él no se le va en
prisión la semana que viene ni tampoco
se le impondrá una fianza con toda
posibilidad se le acuse y se deje que se
regrese a su casa no habrán algunas
condiciones y demás pero recordemos en
un expresidente le asiste una presunción
de inocencia él tiene protección del
servicio secreto verdad Durante este
proceso y lo va a seguir teniendo es un
acusado criminal sujeto
a las directrices del tribunal espero el
tiene el derecho de ver ese caso en
corte y de defenderse no hay una
presunción de inocencia y la fiscalía es
el que tiene el peso de la prueba aquí
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos el
ejército de este país reveló que nueve
soldados fallecieron en el accidente de
dos helicópteros blackhawk en Kentucky
lo que se sabe hasta ahora es que
estaban en una misión de entrenamiento
en la noche del miércoles en la que la
tripulación utilizaba gafas de visión
nocturna luego las aeronaves se
estrellaron en un campo en el condado de
trig ya retiraron las computadoras de
los helicópteros para analizar los datos
y saber con precisión Qué pasó lo que sí
se conoce es que ha sido uno de los
accidentes de entrenamiento militares
más mortíferos que ha habido en Estados
Unidos en los últimos años
en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
se refirió por primera vez al juicio
político en su contra Desde que la corte
constitucional dio luz verde para que la
asamblea nacional lleve a cabo este
procedimiento el mandatario reiteró su
inocencia en el caso por presunta
malversación de fondos públicos y
previamente su gobierno Indicó que daría
la cara ante legislativo en la asamblea
nacional ya se inician los plazos para
darle trámite al juicio político en las
diferentes instancias parlamentarias
esto Dijo lasso soy inocente
en mi vida personal profesional y
pública siempre ha actuado con recta
intención
por tanto
rechazo este juicio político que huele
muy mal y me da la impresión que algunos
asambleístas
se han inventado un juicio político
porque buscan el poder de manera
desesperada
sin límites y por fuera de los tiempos
que establece la democracia
por tanto
respeto la decisión de la corte
constitucional
aunque no la compacta
pasamos a Brasil a donde regresó el
expresidente Yael bolsonaro después de
estar tres meses en Estados Unidos
algunos de sus seguidores lo recibieron
en el aeropuerto de Brasilia Y aunque se
espera que el exmandatario lidere la
oposición él niega que lo hará además
enfrenta varias investigaciones
judiciales Andrés granadillo nos amplía
con innovaciones de sus seguidores así
fue recibido en Brasilia el expresidente
Jair bolsonaro quien llegó este jueves
al país luego de pasar tres meses en
Estados Unidos decenas se acercaron a la
sede del partido liberal formación
política del ex mandatario para saludar
a quien considera el líder de la
oposición bolsonaro en su primer mensaje
desde su llegada a Brasil arremetió
contra el actual mandatario Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva
mostrarle a estas personas que por el
momento y por el corto tiempo que él ha
estado en el poder el no podrá hacer lo
que quiera en el futuro con nuestro país
Nosotros somos prácticamente el 20% de
los asientos en el congreso además de
otros compañeros que están acá de otros
partidos es un gran honor haber
regresado
el partido liberal de bolsonaro tiene la
bancada más grande en la cámara y la
segunda en el senado tras las últimas
elecciones pero a pesar de su fuerza
política bolsonaro tiene que enfrentar
varios problemas legales entre los que
están la supuesta protección a miembros
de su familia de acusaciones de
corrupción el difundir desinformación
sobre el Coby 19 también se le acusa de
difundir desinformación sobre el sistema
de Voto electrónico de Brasil así como
de filtrar información clasificada y por
último Pero no por ello menos importante
se le acusa de incitar a la revuelta sus
partidarios que invadieron el Palacio
presidencial el congreso y el tribunal
supremo tras su derrota electoral además
de esto la semana próxima deberá
presentarse ante la Policía Federal para
esclarecer su conducta con unos valiosos
obsequios que recibió de Arabia Saudita
y que no entregó al estado y que
alcanzarían un valor de alrededor de 3
millones de dólares
en México al menos cinco personas fueron
arrestadas por estar presuntamente
involucradas en la muerte de 39
migrantes en un centro de detención en
Ciudad Juárez en el estado de Chihuahua
las autoridades mexicanas emitieron seis
órdenes de arresto contra tres agentes
de migración dos agentes de seguridad
privada y una persona que Aparentemente
sería quien inició el incendio en el
interior del recinto que terminó con la
vida de los migrantes la mayoría de
ellos guatemaltecos y venezolanos
a lo largo de igual de que vayamos
desarrollando Las investigaciones vamos
a ver la comisión de otros posibles
delitos que tienen que ver también con
el delito de abuso de autoridad
probablemente o incluso malos tratos
vamos a actuar siempre con transparencia
no vamos a ocultar ningún hecho y no
vamos a proteger a ninguna persona la
investigación será transparente para dar
justicia a las personas hay expectativa
en Guatemala por la visita de la
presidenta de Taiwán sai y un buen quien
antes hizo una escala en Estados Unidos
y provocó la ira de China ante los
temores de que la mandataria pueda
reunirse con el líder de la cámara de
representantes sin embargo Washington ha
insistido a Beijing en que no hay nada
de que preocuparse ya que no se trata de
una visita oficial desde la ciudad de
antigua nuestro corresponsal para
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
nos contó Cuál será la agenda de sai y
un buen en esta región del continente
para este viernes 31 de marzo se espera
que el propio canciller Mario bucaro
reciba a las 2 de la tarde hora local en
el aeropuerto de la fuerza aérea de
Guatemala la delegación de Taiwán y de
allí se dirigirán directamente al
Palacio Nacional donde la presidenta de
Taiwán se reunirá a Puerta cerrada con
el presidente Alejandro yamate y esto
previamente después de haberle rendido
honores nosotros como medios de
comunicación
conoceremos lo que ellos dos habrán
conversado en la noche 7:30 hora local
que se espera en esa declaración
conjunta de los dos mandatarios que
hablen de acuerdos de cooperación y de
inversión para el sábado la delegación
taiwanesa visitará las ruinas de Tikal
que es el icono de la arquitectura
indígena maya en Centroamérica y el
domingo visitarán un hospital El de
Chimaltenango que fue construido con
recursos de Taiwán para comenzar la
próxima semana la delegación de Taiwán
irá a Belice se reunirá la presidenta
con el Primer Ministro John briceño y
allí tendrá la oportunidad de hablar
ante el parlamento para justamente decir
que Taiwán es un país que no pertenece a
la china continental y es una nación
soberana
hasta que este Informativo en frases 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]